[Music]
in a place like MIT you have people from
all over the world from very different
backgrounds ethnicities and races and
cultures and the ome is a place where
you can find people that probably have
your same background in my case there's
one of those tough members those poor
Ricans so that's always nice for me to
go in and just talk to her they're open
arms no matter who you are where you're
from coming to a place like MIT was very
intimidating no one in my family had
ever even been to college before we are
minorities here there aren't large
communities for you to fit in and feel
at home and I think that it can take
some time to find those communities and
I think that one may just expedites that
process I'd say that with me has
definitely made my time here less lonely
and less confusing at the core of this
mission to make the world a better place
is empowering students with that mindset
with that mind at hand mindset and
giving them the tools that they need in
order to be effective in that mission
and the army plays a distinctive role in
that and making sure that these students
are successful no matter how small you
think the issue or how big issue might
seem to you like the only is there to
help you in some way even if you don't
think they can like even if it's not
academic the ome is there to support you
all of you and everything that like
could be impacting you while here at MIT
for many students they find within the
ome that this is the community that
becomes through their home it's very
very easy just walk into the office
Sheryl is probably right there says hi
to you and helps you out
it's just like a loving environment you
always leave I think in a good space
when you're like done with anything the
homies doing for you because you can
just feel like the love that it comes
out of doing me host a program called
interphase which it invites incoming
freshmen to spend the summer at MIT gain
community get to know the campus and
also have a taste of the coursework to
get a jump on a new semester I recall
that experience being really
instrumental in helping me to feel a
part of the MIT community the ome is the
perfect partner they develop
relationships with students from the
first moment they step foot on campus so
we can use the expertise that we have in
our support offices and the
relationships that the ome develops with
students to make sure we get students
the the best support possible we have a
portfolio of about 25 different programs
that really do help students navigate
MIT but also think about what they want
to do beyond MIT Seminar Excel is
courses that students take alongside
their curriculum that helped them
succeed it takes a little bit of
momentum at times to get students to
overcome their natural reluctance to say
I don't understand this
I need some help with this what seminar
excelled acts as is essentially an extra
class for students to attend with a few
other students it's often taught by an
upperclassman I struggled in physics
when I was an undergrad and I really
never had any six in high school so when
I came to when I came to MIT it was like
F equals MA and I was like mind blown
and so I took seminar Excel both
semesters my freshman year didn't just
get me by I excelled in the courses I
did well
the talented scholars resource room is a
place for students to gather there is a
study lounge there and we also hire
graduate students and upper division
students to offer free tutoring services
Lauridsen leaders help students to
figure out what graduate programs they
want to apply to to visit those graduate
programs it helps them to actually go to
conferences that would be beneficial to
them to make their applications to
graduate school more robust every
student who's part of laureates and
leaders selects a faculty mentor someone
who agrees to guide through him through
the process of thinking about graduate
school even practical things such as
affording the GRE that just was not
possible at the moment but the Lords and
leaders program made it possible the
mentor advocate partnership the map
program pairs mentors with students we
match them with a faculty member or a
staff member or graduate student or
postdoc who basically is there to be a
support system so we have this holistic
network of support the standard is this
community this cohort of young men who
want to be a support system for one
another they participate in retreats and
workshops
it really helps MIT to be a place where
they feel welcome and they feel support
it momentum is this hands-on
interdisciplinary project-based course
for first-year and second-year students
I was in momentum in IP of 2014 and we
worked on developing autonomous quad
copters that would detect gases and land
on places it was an opportunity for me
to practice my engineering in the team
setting and it was also great because
the momentum final presentations take
place in front of company
representatives so there's a networking
event right after and it's a great way
to use your no plan intended momentum
from your presentation in your
networking activities right after we
have 16 representatives from various
companies and organizations who are here
today because they are excited to meet
all of you the ome has a number of
corporate sponsors and supporters that
come in and
the students about resume writing
dressing for success and sort of being
able to navigate the job and internship
opportunities I'm grace Thanh long
nasa/jpl
I'm here with the naval nuclear
propulsion program I am on the
university programs team here at Google
Cambridge really happy to be here and
happy to talk to you about any
opportunities that might be coming up in
the future we're lucky enough at
Microsoft to have a bunch of full-time
engineers who are MIT alums who are
alums of the ome to be able to come back
and work with those students I think
that's really valuable I think it's
special that those companies come
specifically for they all mean to like
see underrepresented minorities having
staff who understands where they're
coming from where they've invested the
time to build a relationship with
students they know their background they
have interacted with them academically
personally they've spent time with them
outside of those formal programs as well
I think there's definitely a trust that
develops there and that goes a long way
with a student coming out and being
vulnerable and saying hey I need help
the staff and noemi are very much
committed to the mission they're there
because they care it's an oasis in the
middle of the chaos and it's important
to have offices like that people like
that then you feel comfortable with that
just want to help you do your best
because I had this access to these
services from the Army I always felt
comfortable going into my exams I always
feel comfortable completing my courses
success and successes the Army has given
it to me it's all about confidence and
feeling like you understand your
environment it's wonderful for me to be
back here as a faculty member and think
about 28 years ago first being
introduced to the ome and how profound
an impact those programs had on my self
as an individual as well as on my
professional career and it's quite
extraordinary and inspirational to see
it continuing to have such an impact in
the lives of young people
the ome and it's programs say to
students and to the world your presence
at MIT is important you matter and we
believe in you the fact that the ome was
here when I started as an undergraduate
in 1993 and that here in 2018 the Army's
not just still here but has grown it has
expanded their programs like that to me
says a lot about the Institute's
commitment to those of us who are
underrepresented minority about a
generation or two ago someone stood up
and said hey we're going to make this
difference and they started to carve out
of MIT a place in an environment where I
can eventually come in 2010 and say I
feel a little bit more at home than I
thought I would to all the people that
have taking the opportunity and time and
sacrifice in order to prepare a way for
me to pass through for all the
professors that partnered and corporate
partners who all pitched in in order to
make my experience a little bit better
the reason I have made it this far is
because I stand on the shoulders of
giants
you